Corey hardric heading back at
speculation he cheated on why tiamori
following news they're getting a divorce
they have this expectation going into
marriage that everything is going to be
perfect nothing is perfect on Wednesday
the actor defends himself on social
media after an Instagram user suggested
he was unfaithful to Tia leading her to
file for divorce after 14 years of
marriage yeah Corey's reply gets right
to the point simply writing quote lies
when you are open-minded and saying okay
you know there are going to be some days
where I say something that I don't
necessarily mean if I'm like you know
annoyed or whatever
um you know forgive him you forgive
yourself I think that's the the key
illegal documents obtained by ET Tia
cites quote irreconcilable differences
as a reason behind their split
I support her yeah so you know whatever
whatever she wants uh the Maurice have
her back earlier on Wednesday twin
sister Tamir shared how the family is
rallying around Tia I love her dearly
she is strong
um but I know right now she just kind of
just wants to
you know just kind of just process it
all take it all in and you know be a
little private about that and you know
as a sister you know yeah I'm just gonna
respect that it's also worth noting
Tia's brother Taj like Corey's Instagram
post which was shared on Monday perhaps
a sign there's no bad blood between the
families I feel you know grateful E.T
was whipped to you just last week with
the actress still on cloud nine from her
getaway with Corey and their kids in
July to be in Italy again with our
children and our husbands it was just so
amazing and just so wonderful Sia and
Corey met in the early 2000s later tying
the nod in 2008. Corey is really chill
and he's very like laid back and he's
really cool but on his wedding day
I I still feel like I've never seen him
smile as much and as big he cried when
both of our kids were born and he also
shed a tear on our wedding day the pair
welcomed their son in 2011 and their
daughter in 2018. she's only four years
old but I'm a strong believer that
children learn through observation
she's going to learn and see how I
navigate through this world
and so she motivates me to make the
right decisions no matter what those
decisions are as Tia tells it while her
and Corey are going their separate ways
they'll maintain a friendship as a
co-parent she says in part quote these
decisions are never easy and not without
sadness quote I am grateful for all the
happy times we have together and I want
to thank my friends family and fans for
your love and support as we start this
new chapter moving forward in our lives
foreign